so uh let's do a quick review of the
previous lecture as usual so last time
we kind of started you know going uh
into the into the details of uh sonar in
terms of the different types of sonar
systems uh for robotics of course uh and
then um we we kind of did a taxonomy of
of sonar if you will uh so starting with
uh what type of waveforms uh these
systems use for sensing uh the breakdown
is pretty clear so either your system
sends uh short pulses and there's kind
of like a silent time between two
consecutive pulses and during that time
uh it basically is hearing back for the
Echoes from the environment or it is
continuous so that would be a pulse
cycle uh sonar or ultrasonic sensor or
it's continuously transmitting uh
signals and and so there's no silence
time basically it's continuously
transmitting and that's a continuous
transmission frequency modulated or ctfm
sonar
um also
um called fmcw sonar frequency modulated
continuous wave
um this term fmcw is less used in sonar
terminology mostly it's called ctfm but
when we talk about radar you would see
that there's like systems of basically
the exact same type of architecture and
radar and those are called fmcw so
that's why I included so you kind of you
know start
identifying these little different
fields use different terms they are the
same type of systems or principle of
operation
then look we looked in detail at Pulse
Echo sonar in terms of what types of
pulse waveforms they use there's many
many different pulses so there's no you
know standard table of you know just a
few pulses that are used every you know
sensor manufacturer they kind of come up
with their own
version of pulses you can also design
your own so we looked at a few but the
the big divide here is either their
narrow narrow band pulses so those are
basically kind of like a pure sinusoid
with some
amplitude envelope applied to them or
they're white man pulses which are
typically much much shorter and then
they take up more spectral bandwidth
uh in the in the basically in the
frequency domain
how you
you attack range
for Paul cycle sonar uh we also looked
at two main types of algorithms the
first one was the threshold based
ranging which basically you just Rectify
and integrate your received Echo and as
soon as the output of your integrator
passes a a predetermined threshold you
declare a detection a very very simple
algorithm it can even be fully
implemented in analog so you might not
even need to use like a ADC and a DSP
you can you can do it much simpler but
it comes with all uh sorts of uh you
know
um
caveats in terms of specifically the
error in ranging has as has dependency
on the amplitude of the received Echo
and also on the angle of where the
target is and in certain cases we saw
that the error can blow up so there's
there's a trade-off there right you get
something very simple you can get it up
and running quickly and cheap but it's
not the best performing algorithm for
you or you could do uh basically what we
we learned in GPS you can do matched
filtering or correlation based detectors
and for that you basically take your
received Echo and correlate that with
the waveform that was transmitted and
that the output of that correlator
there's going to be a peak and the index
of that Peak corresponds to the round
trip time of flight and then for this as
we know uh of course you would want to
if you're using a match filtering you
would want to use uh waveforms or pulses
with good correlation properties that
give you like a nice sharp Peak with low
side lobes so you could do for instance
marker codes are a good choice that that
are used PN sequences also work of
course but they're a bit Overkill I
would say for for sonar because for
sonar we're dealing with you know short
range applications you don't need codes
with with very high high SNR um okay and
then so so this was about Paul secos
Sona then we started talking about the
ctfm's owner and the ctfm
this FM part of it the frequency
modulation is there because these
systems typically send a very specific
type of waveform which is a linear
frequency chart I mean so what uh what a
linear frequency chip is is it's
basically a signal in the time domain
and it's designed such that if you
calculate the instantaneous frequency of
the signal it varies linearly over time
right so this plot which is a bit of a
you know unusual way of you know
visualizing the signal because either if
you're used to like looking at its
signals in terms of their amplitude
versus time or we looked at their look
at their Fourier transform basically
this is something in between so your
your vertical axis is the instantaneous
frequency horizontal is time okay but it
is the most intuitive way of thinking
about these signals so the instantaneous
frequency let's look at the black first
that's the basically waveform that you
transmit at Time Zero it starts at some
frequency F0 and it just linearly goes
up it could also go down that's just a
choice of slew rate right you can also
ramp it down doesn't matter it's the
same principle
um so with some slew rate B your
frequency basically linearly goes up and
then you transmit for a positive
duration or a waveform duration of of
Big T and then you repeat so I have only
drawn one but basically right after that
because it's it's a continuous
transmission system so as soon as you
finish the first one you start the
second one basically but let's just look
at one for now
um so you start from F0 you go to F0
plus b is your slew rate in hertz per
second right times T which is the
duration so so that uh
Delta frequency here that's the overall
bandwidth that your pulse takes up and
it's called Big it's denoted by Big B
for the bandwidth which is equal to
basically uh slew rate times time B
times T is the total bandwidth what you
receive if is going to be just a delayed
version of what you transmit I mean
there is attenuation also but if you
look at the frequency of it it's just
going to be the same linear frequency
chip or ramp just delayed by some round
trip time of flight time right so you
essentially get the same thing and
really the the beauty of this technique
is that now if you look at the uh the
difference in the instantaneous
frequency of the waveform that you
transmitted and the echo that you've
received first of all that Delta
frequency I mean these are two two
parallel lines right so the Delta
frequency is going to be constant for
the duration that you're receiving the
echo okay and that Delta f as we showed
is proportional to Tau in fact it's
exactly equal to your slew rate time
Style
very simple linear relationship so it's
just B times Tau so B is known right
that's a choice uh that that we make for
the for the waveform that we are
transmitting so all we need to do is
estimate that the difference and the
instantaneous frequency of the echo
that's received uh compared to the to
the original waveform that was
transmitted once that Delta f is known
you divide by B you get your
time-of-flight Tau and you know the time
of flight from that we can we can
basically estimate range you just uh
divide your time of flight by two to go
from round trip to one way and then also
divide by the speed of sound and that
gives you range okay so now today we're
gonna basically start by looking at how
to find this Delta F because that's at
the core of how ctfm sonar Works any
questions before we continue
okay so
um we were looking at the system block
diagram for a ctfm sonar
and we said that
um
really the magic happens uh at this
basically this block here which is
called a mixer or a down converter and
what happens here is that we feed it the
echo signal that we've collected back at
the receiver and sft which is the uh
basically the transmitter right
so that's the trip that we sent and then
it basically outputs some signal which
we call Sif of T which is our
intermediate frequency signal and if
this block is designed right
that s i f of T should have a frequency
at Delta F which is the difference
between the transmitted and the and the
received Echo frequency
and in fact mathematically it turns out
that the operation that that block needs
to do is very simple is is basically
just a complex multiplication so what
that and that's why we show it as a
multiplier because it's actually exactly
multiplying those signals so what it
does is basically it multiplies the
complex conjugate of the echo that you
have received by sft which again s of T
is that trip waveform that we we
generate and and send out
we can break down the echo into two
parts so it has the echo signal has an
amplitude that as we know depends on
range and and the the angle of the
target so it depends on Theta and rho
but the time dependency of it is just a
delayed version of the transmitter chip
right and why the star because we're
we're taking like that mixer block is
conjugating it so that's a operation
that happens inside the mixer so you get
basically uh s star of T minus Tau times
s of T and now we can plug in the
expression that we have for that trip
signal remember let me first go to the
next one but remember s of t
was basically
exponential of something like J 2 pi
some F0 plus b t over 2 times T so so
this was the you know
mathematically what the linear frequency
trip is so you just plug that that in
right so so this here basically is our
sft
and this term
is the SS star of T minus Tau that's why
this has a minus sign and then a lot of
things simplify it's just you know two
exponential terms getting multiplied out
and and you do the math so
um
some terms cancel out but what you're
left with is so of course the MU which
is the gain of the amplifier and this
Echo amplitude just carry over but we're
concerned with you know the time
dependency of it right so what you get
at the end of the day you get e to the
J2 Pi let me go one step further um
so
at inside the exponent you get this B
times Tau times T and that's the only
term that has time dependence and you
get something that depends on like F0
and B and Tau but there's no T
dependency in it so that's just a
constant phase for us right so we can
basically uh refactor this and
this b b times Tau we call that our
Delta F right and everything else just
call that Phi of Tau it's it's just a
constant phase basically for the
duration of of the received Echo and so
we see that this Sif the intermediate
frequency signal that's coming out of
the mixer exactly has the property that
we want it's basically the time
dependency of it like if you ignore
everything else that is not time
dependent like the echo amplitude and
that constant phase the Sif
of T is is proportional to e to the J 2
pi Delta f t which is exactly what we
want so this signal has
instantaneous frequency or it's actually
just a constant frequency that is
proportional to the time of flight Tau
right so basically at this point uh we
have a sensor right because that block
diagram that that we showed if you build
that
the intermediate frequency that we get
if I just go back to the block diagram
real quick so we can look at it together
so this intermediate frequency signal
that we have it's going to get filtered
and passed through an ADC but then the
discretized version that we have
this signal has a frequency that is
proportional to the time of flight so
now to estimate time of flight and
ultimately range all we need to do is to
estimate the frequency of the if signal
right
and again as we know the row which is
the range is is going to be proportional
to the frequency Delta F of the
converted signal via this expression
where is this coming from well we know
rho is basically the time of flight
times the speed of light over 2 and then
we have just plugged in uh uh for for
Tau we have we have plugged in this
expression which is Delta F over B so
that's our time of flight okay so really
the magic or the power of of of of this
idea of ctfm or fmcw is that we have
converted a range estimation problem to
a frequency estimation problem so now we
just need to estimate the frequency of
the signal in in DSP and as I said last
time there is tens or possibly hundreds
of algorithms for for frequency
estimation if you just go on Google and
and and search for spectral estimation
or frequency estimation you would see
tons and tons and tons of papers I mean
some of them go go back you know many
tens of years because it's a problem
that has been studied in statistics and
later in electrical engineering for many
years and people have come up with
really beautiful algorithms for spectral
estimations different algorithms they
have different trade-offs you know some
are more accurate but more
computationally complex some are simpler
not as accurate I mean you get all sorts
of trade-offs between them we're going
to look at the simplest and most
efficient one which you all already know
about which is a Fourier transform right
I mean what Fourier transform is good at
is telling you the spectral content of a
signal now if you have a signal which
basically has just one frequency in it
and you look at its Fourier transform or
the magnitude of the Fourier transform
it will show a Peak at that frequency
right so basically in DSP with our
simple algorithm we just take the
Fourier transform of the the if signal
so this
digitized if signal comes in you take
the Fourier transform off it okay and
you get what what we call Big s i f of K
and then you find Peaks or you look at
basically the magnitude of uh the the
Fourier transform and you look at the
Peaks right
um so what you would typically see if
this this plot down here is the fft of
Sif so um it's uh also plotted in log
scale so that's why we call it DB here
so uh to to be
concrete about it what is being plotted
is 20 times log 10
of the magnitude of the fft
of
s i f of n
that's what this is and that's why it's
in DB because we're taking 20 logs ydb I
mean it's it's just not makes makes a
nicer plot that's that's why I mean
there's really you could you could plot
it in linear scale if you will but the
point here is that uh well you look at
your fft and at some index K hat you're
going to see a peak
right and that index or the frequency of
that index is basically the frequency of
the if signal and then we can convert
that to time of flight end range how do
we convert that to uh frequency well
this simple formula right as as you know
from um Fourier transforms uh well you
get an index right but to go from the
index to the actual frequency in hertz
all you need to do so if if your signal
or if one chirp uh after the ADC had n
samples in it so we are basically taking
an endpoint
fft here that's why our K index goes
from 0 to n minus one we're just looking
at one period of the fft the frequency
varies linearly here right so all you
need to do to go from your index to the
frequency you divide that by n and
multiply that by FS which is the ADC
sampling rate
and that gives you your Delta F hat
which is your estimate of the frequency
of the if signal
okay
um and what is your range estimate then
you just basically
do Delta F hat times the speed of sound
divided by 2 times the slew rate and
that would be the range of your uh your
target okay
and that's it I mean the the the
algorithms for ctfm are really this
simple it's just one fft you do look at
the magnitude take the peak and
convert the index of the peak to the
frequency and then convert the frequency
to time of flight and range and it's all
just you know just linear trans just a
bunch of scalings basically that you
need to do in between to go from index
to frequency to time of flight to to
range okay uh make sure this here makes
sense to you if it doesn't let me know
let's talk about it does this make sense
how we're converting the frequency right
because again when you do the fft for
your index zero index corresponds to
zero frequency and index n corresponds
to the the sampling rate which is FS and
every index in between is just linear
right so every fft bin is basically has
a width of FS Over N where n is the
number of points in the in the fft so
that's why your K hat you just multiply
it by FS over n and that gives you the
actual frequency corresponding to
okay
um
now it turns out so far we just assumed
uh what you've received is is coming
from a single Target
but this also works if you
simultaneously receive Echoes from
multiple targets so let's say you're
sending out the ultrasonic uh beam
pattern that you're sending is wide and
it's hitting multiple Targets in the
scene and within the duration of one
chip you receive multiple Echoes okay
that is fine so what you have is
basically a summation of a bunch of
Echoes and you do the exact same thing
you down convert them and you take the
fft and you're gonna see
multiple Peaks so this is K hat one and
then you get K hat two k hat three
and each gives you the range of one of
the targets so it also uh it's it's very
nice in in that manner that if if you
have if you're hitting more than one
target with with a single uh chip that's
still fine your algorithm uh Works
basically
okay any questions about this
all right let's continue so the next
thing we want to look at is what is the
result the ranging resolution you get
from this and what is the maximum range
that you get from this okay and there is
a trade-off between the two and just
looking back but at this picture I'm
going to clean it up a little bit and
um maybe also cleaned this up
okay and uh just looking at this you can
actually answer both questions so in
terms of uh the the range resolution
that you expect from this it's directly
tied to again the the fft so the the
closest two Targets that you can
possibly distinguish in range is if they
they have two peaks that are exactly one
fft bin apart right like one is at K and
the other one is like at the exact next
spin so that kind of is like the lower
uh lower bound on the on on how how
close to targets can be if they're any
closer they basically fall into the same
fft bin and then you cannot distinguish
them right so that's one and then what
is the maximum range that you can detect
possibly that's where the peak is like
at the very end of the fft right so
that's where basically your Delta F hat
is is equal
to your sampling rate because if the
frequency is any higher than that you
know ffts are periodic and it just wraps
around okay so this picture directly
also tells you the resolution and the
maximum range range resolution and
maximum range that you can get but we
can also mathematically look at what
what they are so uh for for the minimum
range discrimination as I said that you
can do that Delta F Min corresponds to a
single fft bin right and what is the
width the frequency width of one FST bin
that's just your sampling rate divided
by the total number of points in the fft
so it's just FS Over N okay you can also
write it as 1 over T where remember T is
is your total chip duration
duration why is that the case because uh
well you have it you have a chair of of
in time it it's 0 to T and if I just
draw the
waveform of it that's the that's the
chip and then uh in the ADC we're
sampling it in end points right so you
do you do basically discretize it to end
points so then you get this relationship
between the number of points in the
discretized signal and the sampling rate
of the ADC and the total time duration n
equals T times FS okay so that's your
minimum
frequency that you can discriminate with
your fft algorithm but what is the what
what range does that correspond to we
just plug this into our range estimation
equation so our Delta row minimum that's
our range resolution the minimum range
we can discriminate is going to be the
minimum Delta F times the speed of sound
divided by 2B and then for Delta F we
plug in the 1 over T and we get this
expression here right so our ranging
resolution is going to be the speed of
sound divided by two times this slew
rate times the duration of the chip
remember this B times T if we go back to
this this picture we had here
slide it up
B times T is the total bandwidth we set
of the chip right because we go from
frequency 0 f 0 to F0 plus b times Big T
and B times B times the Big T so that's
that's the total uh spectral width of
the chip or the total chip bandwidth
Okay so
so basically our ranging resolution is
just the speed of light divided by 2B so
if you want more resolution you need a
chip with a larger bandwidth which means
either higher slew rate or larger chip
duration so larger b or larger t or both
to get a larger bandwidth that's what we
need okay what about maximum range
maximum detectable range again as we
said it's the maximum Delta F that you
can find in your fft
um
times the speed of sound divided by 2B
and what is the the maximum Delta F it's
almost equal to your fft sampling rate
so you just get your fft sampling rate
times V divided by 2B and that is your
maximum range so here if you want more
range
what should you do either increase the
ADC sampling rate
use the faster ADC that's one way
speed of sound though we don't have any
control over that or you can make the
denominator smaller which means reduce
your slew rate okay so here you see two
opposite effects in terms of this sort
if if you keep everything the same
and just change the slew rate of these
chips and remember this low rate is like
the slope of how quickly you vary the
frequency if I want to increase the slew
rate it's going to go up faster right if
you reduce it it's going to go up slower
so if you just change the slew rate
um what happens is that increasing the
slew rate so larger B
what it does for you is it will
improve the resolution right because
this Delta rho will become smaller which
is a good thing that means you can
discriminate targets that are more
closely spaced in range so you get
better resolution but you're going to
reduce your maximum maximum range right
so there's always a a a a trade off that
that's of course if everything else is
the fix if you it fix if you have
control over some other parameters maybe
you can design your waveforms
differently but just remember that
this B is a design parameter that if
you're in charge of you know using the
sensor or tuning it for your specific
application this is one of the important
design parameters and then you need to
decide what is the right choice of B
that gives you the right trade-off
between maximum range and the range
resolution and and then you basically go
with that
any questions
okay so let's continue so we talked
about
um ranging
um so far and and how it's done in
um both the case of pulse Echo sonar and
uh continuous wave sonar right what we
have not talked about yet is how do you
estimate the bearing angle or the
direction of arrival for the Target now
in terms of bearing estimation uh
there's there's different ways of doing
it
um
and for instance some systems just use a
single receiver
um and from the echo amplitude that they
receive they try to estimate also in
addition to the range the bearing angle
of the of the of the target
um but but as we know uh the dependency
of the echo amplitude on the on the on
the target angle there's a lot that goes
into it right I mean it depends on your
radiation pattern the actual shape of
the target you know a lot of things so
so the systems that only use a single
transducers uh for forbearing estimation
they usually cannot do a good job
because there is so much uncertainty
they have to have you know a signal
model or a fit to you know the
dependency of the echo amplitude to the
to the Target angle uh and and there's
so much variation and and those signal
models that they usually can't do a
great job I mean it kind of works but
it's not not very accurate uh systems
that can do much better bearing
estimation they typically use more than
one transducer so they use at least two
and they use this idea of triangulation
that we will talk about but before we
talk about triangulation there is a very
very interesting geometric trick that
when it comes to
doing the calculations for Target
bearing or DOA it really makes the math
a lot more intuitive and easy and that's
this idea of the virtual emitter this is
a purely purely geometric idea right
there's you know the the it's it's not
new physics we are talking about so
we're just gonna you know do this smart
geometric trick that helps us analyze
the bearing angle a little a little more
easily in math
so um
when it comes to the virtual emitter
targets are very broadly categorized or
divided into three types and it's a very
very broad categorization but it it
nevertheless it's it's okay it gives us
something to to work with so the three
classes of targets for sonar that are
considered uh it's it's plane targets
um so it's a plane it's it's kind of
like a wall just a big flat surface then
you have corners uh which is like the
corner of a wall you know two surfaces
at an angle that is typically assumed to
be 90 degrees and and then you have
edges right again two surfaces but at a
basically an angle that makes an an edge
instead of instead of a corner again I
know it's it's it's very crude right I
mean do you you can argue that oh but I
can I can have like a sphere or
something that is not really any of
these but very very broadly speaking and
in a very uh you know crude manner uh
you can roughly categorize different
targets into these three categories now
what happens this idea of virtual
emitter let's just look at the pictures
here starting with the plane the idea
here is so you have let's say one
transmitter and one receiver okay and uh
and then and then you have your Target
in this case it's it's the plane uh as
as as drawn here and then
um your transmitter receiver plane so so
they are on a plane and they make an
angle Theta
with respect to where the target normal
is okay so so basically the target
bearing is at some angle Theta relative
to the to where the
t-axis is pointing at
um now what happens is that the signal
that goes from the TX to the RX in this
case in the case of a plane
um it's going to basically
get reflected it hits the plane and it
gets reflected and it gets to the RX and
then because it's a plane
um basically that main path from the TX
to the RX is that basically the shortest
path which as we know from geometry the
angle of incidence and the angle of
reflection are going to be equal right
so it's kind of like if it as if it was
a mirror
um now for this geometry here
if I place what we call a virtual
transmitter which is just a mirror image
of the TX with respect to this plane so
you just basically reflect the TX
and put a virtual TX here
and then you remove the plane as if it
wasn't there and now if you transmit
from this virtual TX
the RX is not going to notice any
difference right it's as if the original
TX had transmitted and the plane was
there because it's the same angle of
arrival and it's the same time of light
basically between the virtual TX and the
RX and the actual TX and the RX okay so
that's the idea of the virtual uh
virtual emitter or the virtual
transmitter it's a purely geometric
argument now you might ask what's the
use of it I'll show you in a second but
just to complete if it depends like
where the virtual transmitter is it
depends on the geometry of the target so
if it's a plane as we saw you just
reflect it reflect the transmitter
relative to that plane if it's if it's a
corner your virtual TX is going to be
the reflection of the transmitter with
respect to
basically the corner point right so you
basically reflect it you put your
virtual TX here and then from this
virtual TX to the RX it's going to see
basically as if it was the actual TX the
same same DOA basically finally if you
have an edge your virtual transmitter it
could be the it would be the edge itself
that edge Point becomes basically the
virtual transmitter and one point to
note about Edge targets is that as we
said before when you have Edge targets
The Echoes that reflect back they're
going to be spherical waves because
those essentially act like Point targets
that are very small and then they Echo
back
spherical wave fronts to you okay so
that's that's the idea of the virtual
emitter purely geometric right nothing
really
physically new about it but why is it
useful uh it's useful because it lets us
to do a DOA estimation basically very
easily so as I said the type of DOA
estimation we are going to look at is
going to be based on triangulation so in
this case you have at least two
receivers okay okay so I have RX1 and
rx2 they're separated by some distance D
okay and they have received Echoes and
let's say we know the The Echoes that
are received by the two rx's correspond
to the same physical Target okay but
they're gonna because they're located at
different positions the range that the
two receivers estimate the row is going
to be different right so RX1 is going to
estimate some range Row one and rx2 is
going to estimate some range row two
right but now we can assume both of
these are coming from the same virtual
transmitter so I had one transmitter two
receivers
a Target
okay doesn't matter what it is but
whatever Target it is we can make an
equivalent basically geometry here which
is a virtual transmitter and the two rxs
okay and now the DOA estimation problem
is what is this angle Theta basically
relative to say rx2 and that is the DOA
to the actual Target because we know the
DOA to the virtual TX is going to be
equal to the DOA to the physical Target
okay
but now we have a very simple geometry
basically to solve here because uh um
basically
um we look at you know we have multiple
triangles here but if you look at this
one first
the Highlight in green then in red
the sign of the DOA is going to be given
by D plus h over rho 2 that's that the D
is the separation between the RX and txh
is this additional piece basically here
it's a right triangle right so D plus h
divided by rho 2 that's sine Theta
cosine Theta is is l
over Row 2 right and then we can look at
this top triangle
highlighted in purple
and then in there we see that H is equal
to square root of Row 1 minus L squared
I mean this is pure you know
Pythagoras Theorem and geometry but
basically uh from these three equations
we can solve for Theta
and Theta becomes this the arc sine of D
squared plus rho 2 squared minus rho 1
squared over 2 D times rho 2. what's
nice about this is everything is known
right d is the separation of the two
receivers we know what it is and the row
one and the Row 2 are the ranges that
the two receivers estimated okay you
just plug everything into this you take
the arc sine and that gives you the DOA
to the Target so very simple but what's
important about it is that you need to
know the row one and the Row 2
that you measured whether your two
receivers correspond to the same Target
right if they don't well this argument
is invalid and that's okay if you just
have like one Target in the scene then
you know of course yeah I measure two
ranges they correspond to the same
Target but when you have a very
cluttered scene and then you
simultaneously receive Echoes from many
targets establishing that correspondence
between you know the rows that your
different receivers are estimating
becomes a difficult task so that's one
thing to note the other one to note is
that well this method works and it's
often used but it's important to note
that it couples your bearing estimation
to your range estimation right so
whatever errors that you have in your
range estimation would now get into your
bearing estimation or DOA estimation so
if you use a poor method for ranging
like a threshold based ranging which can
have a very large error then you that
error basically propagates into your DOA
as well and can make your DOA very very
inaccurate okay
had in the previous page is that if if
the receivers are placed very close to
each other
so if that separation D is is much
smaller than the distance to the Target
Row one and row two basically uh the the
expression simplifies because you can
basically ignore uh ignore the
determined in the numerator and and and
make it simpler so then uh your your
varying estimate basically just becomes
our sine of row two minus Row one over
over D very very simple
um expression okay
any questions about DOA estimation
and this is General right this is
independent of like do you have a pulse
Echo sonar or a ctfm or how you're doing
your ranging it doesn't care right all
you need is is two receivers two range
estimates and know that those two range
estimates are are for the same Target
and just and this the rest is just
geometry right so hopefully now uh it
makes sense why we introduce this idea
of the virtual TX or the virtual emitter
because basically uh this this picture
is y right this uh
I lost it
this picture is why because with the
virtual TX you know you just take the
target out of the picture and you just
have a very simple geometry to solve for
for DOA estimation
um that's why it just simplifies the
math basically okay
um
so let's uh
continue as I said so what kind of
accuracy you can get uh with with this
triangulation basically technique you
can get sub degrees I mean in in
in a good day where you know your
environment is not cluttered your SNR is
good and all that you can get close to
like 0.2 degrees or a little better so
that's like what what to estimate if
things are noisy if you have too much
clutter you know you can you can you can
do worse but that's that's what you
could get as I said there are methods
for bearing estimations that just use a
single transducer but those methods need
you know a signal model essentially
which is usually those are data driven
techniques which do a fit to the echo
amplitude as a function of pairing with
a bunch of assumptions basically baked
in and then they use that to
um do bearing angle estimation and those
methods are not very accurate
um so so they can get
at best to like one degree accuracy or
so and it sort of makes sense why
because there's there's too much
variation in the in the signal that a
single receiver would receive as a
function of pairing and other other
parameters so
um just the data-driven approach can
only get you uh get you so far when it
comes to having a signal model to work
with but triangulation you can do you
can do much better you can even do
triangulation with more than two
receivers I mean you can have a bunch
and uh and and even reduce your error uh
even further but two is sort of the
minimum
um you've seen this uh I mean the the
lots of cars many cars and today they
have ultrasonic sensors in their bumpers
and some of them just use that there's
typically four in the bumper and some of
them just use them individually and for
just ranging so they just beep if
something is close to one of the one of
the sensors and that's that's all they
do some of them do something more
advanced so what they have is that they
have transducers with radiation patterns
that kind of overlap so this is one this
is another one this is another one and
this is another one and when the target
is closed it overlaps more than one
antenna so they can they can basically
triangulate it so they do like a row one
to your first transducer and a road row
two to the second transducer and find
actually not just the distance but also
the bearing angle of the Target and they
actually can build like a very crude
kind of like a map around the the car in
close proximity and the cars that
actually the the more you know fancy
cars that for instance have uh uh
automatic parking function uh those
should do this because if you want to
actually automatically park the car
um just a proximity is not enough you
you need to build you know a mini map
around the car uh cameras are not great
at very close range because because of
just the the physical limitations of how
you can place them around the car so
ultrasonic are very good for this
it's a it's an application that is a
great fit for ultrasound because you
need a close range sensing
you are not typically moving very fast
right things are slow so it's okay if
your sensor is a is a little slow so and
you need a solution that is you know
cheap and robust so so ultrasonic sensor
is a great choice for that
Okay so
um
there's something really really cool and
unique to sonar when it comes to varying
angle estimation
which is you can actually do a
classification of targets just based on
DOA okay I mean when we hear
classification
um we typically think about you know
Vision sensors like cameras with you
know fancy neural networks that that do
classification those are of course the
best classifiers out there that can do
very uh sophisticated types of
classification but it turns out that
an ultrasound sensor can do a very crude
classification for you almost for free
so it's just a fun thing to look at and
it's purely again a geometry based
argument
so here what you need is two pairs of of
transducers txrx's so two transmitters
two receivers okay that's the Assumption
and what you do is first you transmit
with the first transmitter tx1 transmits
and then you measure a DOA Theta one
and then you transmit with tx2 and you
measure another DOA Theta 2.
okay and just by comparing the two
thetas you can distinguish the three
types of targets we talked about which
is planes edges and corners and this is
how it works uh again pure geometry uh
let's look at the plane case so I'm I'm
writing these as TRX because it's like a
transmitter receiver you know uh combo
uh thing co-located transmitter receiver
so that's trx1 trx2 so each is both a TX
and RX
and what we're doing let's say first tx1
um sends uh transmits and what DOA do we
measure and we are also looking at DOA
on RX1 let's say okay if it's far away
it doesn't matter which one you look at
but let's say we're just looking at at
RX1 so tx1 fires right what UA do you
measure well we should look at the
virtual uh transmitter corresponding to
tx1 which is the mirror image of of that
relative to the plane so that's number
one right and what DOA do you measure uh
well we measure Theta 1 right I'm going
to highlight it in red okay so that's
your Theta one then tx2 fires what is
the virtual
transmitter for tx2 highlighted and
orange that's number two again you just
reflect TX relative to the plane so
that's number two and what DOA do you
measure with two you measure this larger
angle highlighted in Orange Theta 2
right so if you compare Theta 1 and
Theta 2 or if you look at their
difference which we call PSI which is
Theta 2 minus Theta 1. you see it's a
positive value
okay also what let's the so what it
becomes clear if you look at a different
class of Target so if you look at a
corner for instance uh I'm not going to
do the full
you know walking through the geometry
because it's it's it's kind of obvious
but again you do the same thing you
first do the tx1 look at the
corresponding virtual TX so it's going
to be up here and for tx2 it's going to
be down here and then you look at the
Theta 1 and Theta 2 and now you see for
this type of Target it's
um the exact opposite so Theta 2 minus
Theta 1 becomes negative for for a
corner and if you do that for an edge
you would see that the Theta 1 and Theta
2 become equal
which is pretty cool I mean it's it's
very limited what you can do with this
right but it's kind of interesting that
just by pure geometry you can do like a
very simple classification and and so on
I thought it's it's just uh cool to
point that out
um so you just again have two
transmitters two receivers and do your
dos estimation twice and just by that
Delta difference in the angle you can
you can do a bit of classification any
questions yes
is it the plane you mean or
uh why would it be zero could you say
that again
with the angle between the virtual dx1
and the trx1 right
yeah but but when we talk about the
angle remember that oops sorry um
remember that there is a plane here
right so our our tx's and our X's have
their normal which is this highlighted
okay so the angles are relative to that
if it was directly pointing
to the to the plane yes you would we
would measure zero
um but but not
um when there is a there is an angle
um okay
so
um last part uh about about sonar is
basically
um this idea of ego motion effect so
this is a big limitation of of
ultrasonic sensors which basically is
um boils down to the fact that the speed
of sound is not that high okay it's it's
like
340 or 30 meters per second so what can
happen is that if your sensor is mounted
on a platform that is moving a robot
that is moving okay and that's what we
mean by ego motion so so if the sensor
moves what can happen is that
when your transmitter transmits a
waveform by the time the echo is
received back you are at a different
position right and that position well
you might think oh but we can ignore it
uh well it turns out that no it's it's
not negligible even if you're moving at
like a few meters per second which is
one percent of the speed of sound that
effect can be significant so by the time
you receive the echo your platform has
moved enough that that movement is going
to cause errors in the range and the
bearing angle estimation okay so that's
the idea of uh ego motion effect and it
deter depends on a few factors one is of
course the movement or the the velocity
of the of the robot that the sensor is
mounted on the higher the velocity the
bigger these effects are the the type of
motion also matters typically uh linear
motion is much worse than rotational
motion additional motion is usually not
too bad except if it's at very high
angular velocities but linear motion
again even like a few meters per second
you can get like a 0.6 degree bearing
angle error up to that which is
significant right and also the effect
depends on the geometry of the target so
again a plane versus an edge versus a
corner effect uh differently both the
when it comes to Ego motion the range
and the the bearing okay so
um
sometimes you can have algorithms that
compensate this effect to some extent
but the algorithms tend to become a bit
too complex and also not perfect so
oftentimes they're not actually used but
just know that in algorithm you can
compensate to some extent the the ego
motion now the exact effect that ego
motion has on the Range and the bearing
angle it you can calculate it for every
type of Target and in fact it is done in
the notes but I'm not gonna bore you
with it because it's purely geometric
arguments and I'll let you read it in
the notes it's very detailed derivations
for every type of Target but just set it
up for you so you know if you read this
how how the calculation is being done
basically
we look at different types of targets
starting with the plane okay and we
assume there is
a a transducer that is moving at some
velocity U so at the time of transmit
it's at this position highlighted in red
and the by the time it receives the echo
it's at this purple position so it
basically moves by this much
from the time it transmits the wave to
the time it receives the echo so
basically the round trip path of sound
is for the plane case is this right and
then
as usual we have our frame of reference
that's the x-axis that's the y-axis and
the velocity is used so how it has an X
component and a y component okay if the
platform was a stationary it would stay
just at at this point what it would
measure in terms of uh the range to the
Target would be D right d is this
distance so it would just hit the wall
and come back and your sensor would be
at the same place so it would measure D
now because it is moving it's going to
measure a different range and a
different time of flight you can exactly
solve for that and again I'll let you
read the math because it's pure geometry
but for instance for the case of a plane
Target it it comes to this which is your
actual the time of flight that you
measure is going to be this Tau 0 is the
time of flight with no ego motion so if
your transducer was a stationary but now
because of the ego motion now you have
this dependency on the X and the Y
component component of your ego velocity
and in this case in the case of a planar
Target depending on what u x and u y are
you can measure a time of flight that is
bigger or smaller than Tau 0 which is
the stationary case which kind of makes
sense if you're moving towards the wall
for instance you're going to measure a
shorter time of flight if you're moving
away from it you're going to measure a
longer time of flight so the effect the
point here is you can exactly calculate
them just from geometry and you can
because you can calculate them you can
come up with algorithms to compensate
them to some extent and it's also highly
dependent on the velocity and the and
the geometry of the target you could do
the same calculation for angle of
arrival again it's it's all in the notes
I'm I'm not going to go through that all
because it's it's kind of a kind of a
thing you need to kind of sit down and
you know at your own pace go through it
otherwise it becomes very dry if you do
it here any questions
okay
so we are pretty much done with the
discussion of of sonar I just want to
kind of uh um summarize it all so we we
learned about the physics of sonar you
know the system architecture different
type of waveforms how you process them
how you estimate range and and and
bearing uh and as we did this we also
learned about all the uh limitations of
of sonar sensors so very specifically
for instance uh if you have wide beam
patterns that those can affect in poor
bearing resolution uh we know that the
sensing rate is is not going to be very
high in sonar because you're basically
limited by the speed of sound uh the
range is limited because of the high
attenuation of a factor of sound waves
in air
we also know if you have smooth surfaces
at very uh oblique angles you might not
receive any Echoes from them because
most of the sound that hits it is going
to bounce off away from you so sonar
typically has a hard time
detecting targets at oblique angles
um
you can have false detections because of
you know large side lobes in your beam
pattern or you know other
non-idealities in your in your signals
uh just to make matters more complicated
humidity and temperature variations in
in air cause changes in the speed of
sound and every calculation that we did
as you you saw for ranging and bearing
angle estimation
the speed of sound goes into those
equations and you always assume some
constant for it and if that constant
doesn't change what the physical speed
of sound is that's an additional source
of air so all in all what kind of
performance can you expect from kind of
your your sonar sensor maximum range uh
10 to 15 meters I would say and again
these numbers are not set in stone like
I'm sure you can get more than this with
with some effort but these are you know
typical numbers to expect from a good
sonar for for robotics range resolution
a few centimeters up to like 10 20
centimeters uh bearing resolution
depending on how you do it you can do
0.2 degrees maybe one degree and you can
do about 10 to 40 measurements per
second okay
so I mean if you look at this slide
you're going to see like everything here
is is like a negative right
um so these are all you know limitations
but I hope this doesn't come through as
okay so sonar is useless now that's
that's by no means the case it's
actually can be very very useful uh it
all depends on your applications right
what what are you trying to do and what
type of autonomy you're trying to do and
uh what are the constraints you need to
work with and actually sonar can be a
perfect fit so uh that like automated
parking for instance is one case where
sonar is a very very good fit so
typically if you're in short range cases
you don't have very fast ego motion
right things are kind of stationary or
moving slowly uh you don't need like
crazy high angular resolution
um and you don't need crazy high uh
measurement rates but you're looking for
something reliable and cheap with not a
lot of you know power or compute
resources sonar can be perfect okay
let's look at one simple example of how
sonar mapping Works in action in
robotics if I can open this link okay
before I play this what you're about to
see it's a little dark but so let me
actually go to the here so it's it's a
room that is being videoed from the top
okay and then there's this little robot
thing that that that is moving around
the room and there is some objects you
have a box here and a box here and a
wall and another little box in the
center and it has one sonar sensor
mapped on it mounted on it and it's
going to map the room as it moves around
okay so it's a mapping application in in
in robotics arena for our robot we place
two objects in the corner and the glass
object in the middle of the Arena I
can't stop the audio
panels and one glass surface as the
robot so here we're they're showing
basically the live output of the of the
map that is being generated by by the
sonar sensor so as it does arranging and
appearing angle estimation it puts one
dot in in this 3D plot basically each is
a Target that is is it is it navigates
the arena you can see it's 3D range data
being published on the point cloud
so that's the kind of speed that you get
you know it's kind it's slow right it's
not the fastest it's not crazy high
resolution but again it could be useful
I mean it's if you give it enough time
it's gonna build a decent map I'm gonna
fast forward a little bit
um so you see it's kind of
towards the end we get raw data points
describing the complete raw data points
describing the complete Arena if I stop
here I mean it's not bad right it got
the so that's one of the boxes that's
the other box that's the thing in the
center a lot of false positives right
like stuff around here is all false
positive some stuff it detected Behind
the Walls those are false positive so
it's not perfect not super high
resolution nevertheless it could be
pretty useful I mean these things are
going to be very cheap very low power
very low compute okay one more thing to
note before we close the chapter on
Sonar is that the type of sonar we
talked about everything we talked about
is is I was very targeted to robotic
autonomy applications in other
applications you can have sonar uh with
different transducer designs different
type of DSP different frequencies and
then you get very different types of uh
um outputs basically from them medical
applications is one right as we said
those operate at much much higher
frequencies ranges much shorter but
that's okay for medical applications
because they're at high frequencies they
can have much smaller transducers and
many more of them so they have big
arrays of Piezo or mems transducers and
then they can get much better angular
resolution for instance so the numbers
that you're talking about if you if you
talk to a person who works in medical
sonar they might say oh what what are
you talking about we can get 10 or 100
times better than this yes for that
application because they're working with
you know at different frequencies with
different you know constraints for
robotics these are
the ballpark numbers that that you would
estimate another type of sonar which is
actually very common not for robotic
autonomy but uh in in in in other fields
is they do sonar underwater
and the idea is called synthetic
aperture sonar where they actually very
slowly move their transducers and uh in
with with some uh very clever techniques
and Signal processing they can
effectively generate uh virtual
apertures that are much larger than the
physical aperture and as we know the
beam width goes inversely with the
aperture size so they can in dsv
basically synthesize this very tight
sonar beams underwater and then with
that they can do extremely high
resolution images like this one that you
see it it looks like just a picture but
it's actually a 3D image it has depth
information so it's a it's a ship from
World War II that was sunk and it was a
Norwegian tanker and this is a sonar
picture of it extremely high resolution
but this picture this can take hours to
you know collect all the data because
they're very slow slowly you know moving
their their transducers underwater it
also requires very high
amount of compute to to generate it's
all done in post-processing so it's not
like live view you're going to get this
image no this is you know hours of data
collection maybe another hour of or two
of you know crunching the data and then
eventually uh you get this again not
useful for robotic autonomy but just so
you know sonar and in other applications
can do a very high resolution things
questions
yes
you have a y solder can achieve high
resolution like radar also uses the fmcw
but why it cannot achieve the wavelength
for some some reason so the question was
why sonar cannot achieve high resolution
was that the question or or
can I oh actually radar also can uh so
when you when we talk about sonar uh
resolution first radar can do better
resolution than than sonar right it's
all about uh and by resolution are we
talking about angle resolution or range
resolution or angle resolution okay so
for sonar we said like point point two
degrees or or so right uh well uh yes
you can do that for you know again on a
good day right like you have good SNR
you don't have a very collateral scene
um you know everything looks good and
and you can achieve that radar also can
approach that uh and with better
algorithms I mean we haven't talked
about radar yet but when we talk to it
um with better algorithms like if you
use super resolution DOA algorithms in
radar you can you can uh do even better
than like 0.2 degrees it really boils
down to two things how for radar how big
is the aperture and what type of signal
processing algorithms you can do I know
my answer is a little awake right now
because we haven't talked about radar
but when we do remind me of of this
question and we can talk about you know
the resolution limits for for radar but
it can get close to this or better yeah
um okay
other questions
all right so now we can start uh talking
about radar
so radar um is another active sensor uh
used for for robotic mapping and
um
the main difference with sonar is
basically that it it uses
electromagnetic radiation instead of
waves instead of sound waves at radio
frequencies so it can determine range it
can determine a angle or direction of
arrival as we'll see it can also
detect radial velocity of targets using
the Doppler effect
um a little bit of History so the first
the concept was proposed in early 1900s
by Irish Hertz but the actual first
deployment of of radar was
filled by
basically World War the second world war
as a similar to many other
technologies that
basically they were developed during the
war
um so the first
field deployment of of of of Radars uh
it was what was called chain home radar
at the time and it was built by uh the
the British royal Air Force and deployed
in 1938 and uh chain home was a
fascinating thing so it was basically a
number of radar antennas that were built
along the uh east coast of uh United
Kingdom it was operating at a frequency
of between 20 and 30 megahertz and it
had a pretty long range it could
detect up to 99 miles and it was purely
designed and built as an early warning
system
for basically the German aircrafts that
could come and and attack the the UK and
it was one of the main reasons that
Germans actually never successfully
attacked the UK during that the world
war because the the chain home did such
a nice job of of the early warning so
they had 21 sites along the coast and uh
here's a picture so there was the
antennas were huge Towers uh uh 360 feet
tall and each transmit antenna was
basically two towers and the actual
antenna was basically hanging from the
from the two towers it was like a dipole
antenna structure huge thing receive
antennas were smaller single towers and
and here on the map you see each dot is
basically
basically one of these and and here's a
picture of one of the sides so they had
21 sides it was a huge effort right
um fun part and at the time
essentially there was no Digital Signal
processing so
the signals were processed by humans so
they were basically collecting these
signals from their Radars in real time
and they had these officers full of
Engineers looking at the signals and
trying to figure out what is the range
and what is the DOA
fascinating but it was it actually
worked
um so that was radar
uh in 1939 today it's everywhere
um I mean from astronomy to Medical
applications to robotics to Aviation uh
even like as you go to the airport this
uh fun little things in the airport
security which have you do this and then
it rotates around you there's actually a
big radar antenna array in them
um it doesn't show the actual output but
these things have extremely high
resolution so when you stand in there
the device is actually doing a very high
resolution picture of you and if you're
concealing something it can it can
detect it
the actual output that it shows the the
the the the uh
TSA agents is not this it just
Highlights part of the body if if it
thinks something is there but it's
actually a super super high resolution
radar and this thing cars have Radars
today you know just the collision
avoidance and and other things but it's
it's everywhere modern day uh radar it's
really
um
um deployed very widely so um
uh we're going to do the usual thing uh
start with the physics right and as you
know and the physics of radar of course
we're going to talk about
electromagnetic waves and also
um how antennas work basically and then
uh from there we're going to talk about
the system architecture how you do
ranging how you do angle estimation how
you do velocity estimation and also
along the way just like we did for sonar
we do a little bit of taxonomy of you
know different different types of of
radar it's going to be our biggest
chapter in the course so we will
probably spend something like five
lectures on it for a good reason because
radar I think
is well as I said it's it's been around
for a long time right since the 1930s or
so but it's really very recently that
people started paying attention to it as
a very useful sensor for for autonomy
and Robotics all the
previous work on radar was very driven
by military Aviation and astronomy so a
ton of progress has been made there but
for very different types of applications
so very different types of Radars have
been you know designed so the type of
radar that for instance you you use in
an airport or on an airplane or on a
tank it's not useful for robotics it's
useful for those applications so that's
why for radar and Robotics it's still a
extremely active field of research
across the board from the hardware
design to you know the algorithms signal
models simulation you know there's a lot
of very interesting work being done here
and I think it's one of those sensors or
probably the main sensor for robotic
applications that we're still in my
opinion and about like 10 to 20 years
ago way from it getting to the full
maturity level
so and by maturity level I mean like
maybe the gold standard of something
like cameras digital cameras are
extremely mature these days I mean you
can buy them cheap and robust and you
know
extremely good uh performance
Radars again for autonomy robotics
they're not there yet we've made a ton
of progress but it's still a very hot
active feel and that's why I want to
really spend the time on it and and and
really give it the attention it deserves
Okay so starting with the physics
The Radars use electromagnetic radiation
so these are waves that that propagate
in in free space and
they can be at different frequencies uh
Radars use RF radio frequency waves and
then later when we talk about lidar it's
the exact same physics just at much
higher frequency and that's Optical
frequencies that's where light is but
the physics is the same it's it's
electromagnetic radiation and typically
you have a electric field we call that e
and a magnetic field called H and these
two fields are always coupled and
propagate together and in many
applications as we'll see they're
actually the field vectors are
orthogonal to each other as shown here
in in red and blue and just like
acoustic waves they have a wavelength
Lambda
and also you have a direction of of
propagation so they're traveling in a
certain direction in the in in free
space
okay so the electromagnetic fields as
you might remember from a Physics course
you've taken they are the physics of
them is is governed by the extremely
famous Maxwell's equations right so
Maxwell equations is a set of four
differential equations that are pretty
much completely you know uh describes
the physics of electromagnetic waves and
the equations are in terms of the
electric and magnetic field uh very
specifically they say that the
Divergence of the electric field is
equal to rho which is the charge density
electric charge density divided by
Epsilon which is a constant and it's the
primitivity of the medium
then they say the second equation is
Divergence of H equals zero so H is a
Divergence free field as we say then we
have the curl of e which is equal to a
constant times the time derivative of H
okay and that constant mu is the
permeability of the medium
and finally we have the curl of H which
is equal to J which is the electric
current density in the medium plus the
permittivity times the time derivative
of e okay so what matters for us here is
uh really the important thing is as
these two last equations show you
there's two things that can give rise to
electromagnetic radiation one is if you
have a time varying magnetic field so if
this uh partial H partial T term is
non-zero that gives rise to an electric
field right because then the curl of e
becomes non-zero and also from the last
equation we see that if you have a
current distribution that can vary with
time that can give rise to a magnetic
field or if you have a time varying
electric field that can also give rise
to a magnetic field so that's why the
electric and the magnetic field always
go together because if one of them is
basically radiating and it's varying
with time because of the Maxwell's
equations the other one also has to be a
non-zero and just to remind ourselves
what is the Divergence and the curve
these are the curl these are just from
from calculus we know the Divergence of
of e and and remember e and H these are
vector Fields right so these are fields
in R3 right so they have an X and A Y
and a z component and the Divergence of
e it's a scalar value which is just the
sum of the three partial derivatives if
e with respect to X Y and Z so
Divergence of e is just a scalar right
right and the curl of a field is is
given by this bigger expression it's
also related to its partial derivatives
with respect to X Y and Z but the curl
is a vector right it's it's a vector in
R3 so that's just a mathematical
definition of a Divergence and a uh
Carol I think this is a good place to
stop because we're almost out of time
and then we'll continue next time any
questions
no all right